i
plus d'une centaine d'enfants
depuis ses débuts comme famille
d'accueil à Amos, il y a 24 ans.
Aujourd'hui, quatre des sixhéhe
ont été forcés de se déplacer
à plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres pour avoir
une place en milieUIUIUIUIUIUIU,
parent d'accueil
- Ilt t t été déracinés,
effectivement, par manque
de place. On va prendre...
il y a zéro place de disponible.
Donc, ils bebebesoin de faire
un placement, un enfant qui est
en négligence puis qu'il fsososs
de place, là!
- Pour Geneviève Rioux,
qui agit comme famille d'accueil
à Trois-Rivières, la situation
Pourtant, selon elle,
laurururie était prévisible.
GENEVIÈVE RIOUX, prés., Féd. des
familles d'accueil du Québec
les établissements. Je parlais
avec lstèstèstèstère puis on le
nommait : vous vous en allez
en dans un mur, on va manquer
pas soin de nous. Les gens sont
ésésésés. Le recrutement ne se
fait pas puis on voyait le
nombre diminuer de plus en pluss
entraîne aussi certains enjeux
liés au transport que doivent
assumer les familles d'accueil,
que ce soit pour les suivis
médicaux dans la ville d'origine
ou pour entretenir le lien
avec la famille biologique.
- Aux enjeux de distance
s'ajoutent les contraintes
le ministère prévoit
un dédommagement quotidien
de 12 dollars par enfant
les produits hygiéniques.
Plusieurs familles d'accueil
dénoncent également la charget r
les plans d'intervention et les
interactions avec établissements
de placement.
SYLVioioioioioioioioioioioioioie
- Je ne pense pas que ce soit
unuiuiuiuiui fasse en sorte que,
vraiment, t'sais, on a beaucoup
de familles d'accueil qui se
de livre qui... qui n'est pasmps
peut-être que ça en fait partie.
- La DPJ soutient plutôt quénéne
serait le manque d'information
tant pour les nouvelles familles
que pour les familles d'accueil
le ministre responsable
des services sociaux,ééééééééééé
notre demande ......
Ici Guillaume Renaud,